this is a game that I'm prepared to show
you I played this game in 2007 at the
continental championship and my opponent
is Grandmaster Kevin sprocket from
Canada and I'm playing with the white
pieces in this game so I start out with
before and this is a move that I play
off on my career so my plan played f5
and this was the first surprise in this
game because he didn't you know when I
prepare against him I didn't see him
play domine - defense game so again the
opening is Dutch defense and it's a it's
interesting opening you don't see that
many very top grandmasters play this
opening but it's not so easy to play
against and unless you know the theory
or have some setup so I usually play 93
in this position against the Dutch
defense because I would like to play E
for and try to get a control of the
square but it's not a busy because
usually black is trying to control the
square himself so he played Knight f6 so
he's preventing me from playing key for
for example if you place a six I play E
for pawn takes e4 94 Knight f6 Bishop g5
Bishop e7 there was a very famous game
played exactly 100 years ago and between
some very strong grandmasters last
katanas
so as a bi familiar with this game it's
a very famous game last gift almost now
ok I can quickly show you this game
because it will be very nice for you to
see this idea so if you place a 6 it's
not a very good move because of the e4
idea so easy to play efore takes if it
goes Knight f6 Bishop g5
Bishop e7 Bishop takes f6 Bishop takes
f6 Knight f3 castles Bishop d3 now black
played b6 in that game the best move
here is 96 and now white immediately
goes 95 activating this knight black
cause Bishop d7 and this is not my game
this is the game I mentioned last
customers
so why place queen h5 obviously
threatening to take on f6 and take 1 X 7
so Thomas played Queen e7 this is a
critical position here anybody familiar
with this position Yeah right
raise your hand if you if you've seen
this game a few if you okay great okay
so we have few people but a lot of
people are not familiar with this so
this is would be excellent for you to
see this game so now why to play and
white is winning here by force and you
don't want to take Knight xf6 here
because if you do that he will just
simply take what a pawn and protect the
h7 pawn at the same time so instead ok
let's see we can tell me the move now
Jason Queen takes h7 sacrificing the
Queen ok
yeah we will look right now so he has to
take now you have to double checks here
Knight f6 or 95 so you want to go with
Knight f6 check now black has two
options we can go here or here if he
goes here
96 mate so he cannot do that so he has
to play King h6 now see you have 2
different ways to check from the g4
square but you have to calculate because
at this point you have to start
calculate and try to find a mate
so force maid
five or six moles here so what's the
correct move here mr. Breen is putting
the night dissolve of six back shaking
and you go pull them on down until you
may put the roots well you have to be
precise if you precise you know the
night that night this night yeah pull
back here yeah well you could try this
you definitely have some threads but
actually you want to play night eg4
check here because you want to have the
night on at 6:00 controlling this square
now it's only one move King g5 now you
need to follow it up here how h4 h4 kink
f6 g3 check King f3 this is no fool
check now row gauge to check and what's
the final move of this game haha so this
is a very famous game okay last year
Tomas 1912 so it will be good for you to
know this game just an idea that you
know in the Dutch defense white
sacrifice the Queen and basically drove
the King all the way from g8
that's where the sacrifice all the way
to g1 and checkmate teammate end with
the long castle okay yeah I knew this
game but of course and that is not gonna
allow me to play this is a strong
Grandmaster so the reason I wanted to
show you this game quickly so you can
see that is six is very dangerous to
play here because when you play six you
lose the control of the e4 square and in
any Dutch defense it's very important
for you to have that control if you play
with black so that's why my opponent
played Knight f6 I play Bishop g5 now I
would like to take this night and at
least give him double pants and if you
play the movie six what can I do here to
try
suppose because interest we have lots of
transpositions we can reach the same
position to a different move order now
we can do that to which move here before
very good with like efore and now
threatening e5 and also capturing on f5
so he has to go he has to take basically
and now we go 94 and this will lead to
the same position because he has to go
Bishop e7 and for example if it doesn't
play let's say he plays knight c6 it's a
really bad move here how can you take
advantage of it you can take with the
better and you know exactly then you
come with a check with a queen and now
he has to move the King and very
dangerous okay so that's why it's
dangerous for him to do that so my
opponent played d5 and now I took the
night he has to take back with the e
pawn here because if he takes with a
jeep on white is a very strong move here
but it's almost winning the game issue
why to play and win he force you okay
now if he takes with the F pawn queen
check he has to come up clean check it
goes back and you take not only your up
upon but he actually lost his turn to
castle because he already moved his king
so you will just simply follow it up in
this position with Knight f3 Bishop c4
long Castle Brooke H e1 and a winning
position so you wrap up on better
position and he cannot castle so that's
why when you play Bishop takes f6 it has
to take back with the e pawn
just second okay so he took eat xf6 and
now I played III Bishop e6 now we're
developing a plate Queen f3 96
now in this position what do you think
how should I try to develop this pieces
here what's the best setup here for
white where should I put the bishop and
then the knight on g1 yes
you could go Bishop b5 which should be
five is the possibility an RV 3 or d3
yes you can also play d'etre
at first I play Bishop b5 because I'm
creating a threat to take so he played
Queen d6
I cannae g2 in this position you want to
have a night only two because you will
have the possibility of going to f4 and
put pressure on the bishop and the pawn
on d5 now a castle
a tree this is unnecessary move in this
position because you want to control the
be Foursquare and later on in the game
you can play Knight a 495 which I did
and you don't have to worry about his
Queen coming to before and giving you a
check and also you can also play v4 so
you really want to have this move in
this position to be able to play before
and also control the square to create
King ba and now 98 for improving the
position of the night so normally we
always say that you need to cancel here
but here I'm not sure where I where I
want to cancel here because I'm planning
actually to advance my pants on the
Queen side so I don't want to cancel
there and if I cancel to the Kings side
then he will immediately start advancing
his pawns so at the moment position is
closed so it's not really necessary to
castle immediately so that's why I
played Knight a 4 with idea to go to c5
improve the position of this Knight
97-95 Bishop c8 now g3
because one thing you need to watch out
black always wants to play the F form of
here and try to undo his double pawns
and at the same time also open the
diagonal for the logical Bishop so this
is something you should be looking for
so that's why I played g3 so I control
the f4 square so he cannot play that
move now I play the h5 trying to play h4
and try to get some counter play on H
file page H for stopping him first what
I want to do I want to stop his control
on the King side and then continue with
my plan and this is very important when
you're playing you don't just focus on
what you want to do you also want to see
what your opponent is start trying to do
and try to prevent his counter play
ninth a g6 and now I stopped this
counter play with therefore and b4 time
to gain some more space on the Queen
side
is a very close position here Bishop h6
c3 strengthening the position if you
notice that my if you look at my plans
now all my plans are in the dark squares
but my light squares are not that weak
because I have a light square Bishop and
black is crumb can't really take
advantage of it like you can't really
put a night only for and which is one of
the main ideas for black somehow to
bring the night only for and the only
way to do that he needs to first move
this Bishop go Knight c8 then also find
a square for the Queen to go a ninety
six ninety four it's a very long plan
but this is the main goal if you ever
reach this position with the black
pieces your main goal is to put your
night only four if you manage to do that
then you're going to have a nice
position but I think at this point it's
very difficult for him to do that
so he played King a eight and now I
continue a four c6 Bishop d3
they look a 8 now if I play b5 it's not
going to be good because he will just
play a 5 ok so if I play b5 we just
place a 5 and I don't have anything so I
play king d2 now my king is very safe in
the middle of the board and that way now
I connect my rocks
he played King a7 after he plays King a7
he has a track
what is it threatening it's a positional
threat he's not trying to win anything
he's just trying to move one of my
strong pieces yes he's threatening to
play b6 and move my knight from c5 my
knight is very strong in this position
not only putting pressure on that on
this panel B 786 also makes his queen
actually doesn't have any squares
because Knight is guarding very
important squares p6 e 67 and putting
pressure on b7 here on a sec so I played
I played a 5 so he cannot do that and
now I'm threatening to play b5 here so
it played c6 okay so now for a moment it
looks like how can white break through
here looks like really neither side can
do much if I mean I can't really play b5
here and I have a c4 break but do I
really want to play c4 here with my King
in the middle and his rooks really lined
up here on e and D file I think will be
very dangerous for me to do that so I
want you to spend some time here don't
rush
spend a minute or two think about it and
let me know if you have a plan here for
white how to break through in this
position here white has a very big
advantage but you need the plan
to break through to the solid defense
what would you do here if you're playing
this position with the white pieces
yeah raise your hand if you have a plum
I now ask you yes go ahead with our rule
and the fire moves light over the water
forces sticks inside break the beam
break you yeah well you want to double
the rooks on a file yeah all over the
routine duty file uh-huh the book light
over okay you have an idea you have an
idea but let's see if someone else can
give us also something yes it's an idea
but my knight on c5 is placed very well
and my night is better than his bishop
and I really don't want to move the
knight because it makes this position
makes very difficult for him actually to
find a move so that's why you don't want
to move the knight the 90s on the best
square here you can have and the plan of
taking the night Bishop then sacrificing
on a6 I think he's too solid there I
mean he can take back with opponent so
you really want to leave the knight on
c5 here yes I would do I'll take that
night there's only two and put it like
on c1 and I will manipulate it up to p3
and get ready because you can also do
but at ideas down on e - yeah it's also
bad your queen up you can have a
position yourself up massive attack sure
from Queen behind the bishop and put the
other night Lou it up to a b3 and be
ready for an attack good luck for him 10
it's an idea but at the meantime you you
have to watch out for the break g5 + f4
this is something you need to watch out
if you move all your pieces away
he can even even sacrifice a pawn and
then see right away this Bishop will
come in to g4 with the temple so it's a
it's not something I can just focus
everything I have to also keep my eye on
to the King side because I have to watch
out for the g5 + f4 this is what he's
trying to do I constantly have to watch
out for this g5 + f4 so first I want to
make a move here that will control even
more squares and really black is going
to have limited moves now after my next
move
try to see which piece you can try to
improve yes excellent Knight f4
yeah so I paid 9f for now I'm putting
pressure on g6 and controlling more
squares it's very difficult for black to
find a move he doesn't have that many
options now yes he could he could but he
could do that but the thing is after I
will take the Jeep on of course
and now another target that we can
double up our rooks on so and again
after this he can really forget about
making any breakthrough with f4 because
my phone is already on f4 and g5 is very
difficult for him to do because I will
just take in a tribe so this way he will
basically have absolutely no control a
now and a weak pawn on g6 that I will
always put pressure on in this position
you will have have to keep your knight
only 7 otherwise you could lose the g6
pawn so I was thinking yeah if he takes
but then I take back and you lose your
two bishops so he didn't do that but
again what's the plan okay rookies and I
went Knight f4 this is a good move but
then he goes here we still need the plan
we have an excellent position here but
how do we break through here to win this
game
now if you look at the position of which
two pieces you want to improve I think
most of my pieces are very well placed
but I have few pieces that needs to be
improved here would you pull the Queen
back right next to you okay that's a
possibility but first which piece you
wanna improve here yes Queen Queen a
stroke the reason I don't want to move
the age hook yet because I need to watch
out for the GFI break so I want to move
that H hooked last because he might play
g5 so I want to make sure I can capture
on g5 and take the pawn on h5 years I
have pressure so I don't want to move
the move this rook yet but my a rock
this is the move this is the piece I can
move so I move my rook to first I played
King c2 to ensure the safety of the King
go away from the diagonal it doesn't
really matter this move or the rook move
because he doesn't have moves here like
he is just going to go go back and forth
and now Queen e2 putting pressure look
II ate and now the plan is to play rook
be one I'm planning to develop my rooks
after making this move King C to Queenie
to improving the position of the Queen
and now we're ready to double up the
rooks on a B file and play b5 this is
what I'm planning to do rook comes up
Brook HP one and then I have all my
pieces now focused on the Queen side and
then go for b5 so he played rook h7
rugby to
and now he realized that after I play
hook HP 1 and B 5 I'm going to win a
game and he's going to lose without
creating any counter play and he decided
to go 45 it's a good decision because
instead of just losing after b5 he at
least tries to complicate the position
Knight xh5 winning upon and now he
played rook to h8 and here I have a
choice to capture on g5 and if it takes
back played g4 and try to convert my ex
upon advantage I have or continue with
my plan but then I have to sacrifice my
knight
so which one you think is the best here
just take take and go g-force by this
much better but now it's going to be
different type of game I'm up on and I
have to try to convert my advantage or
because he wants to move the bishop back
to f8 after which my knight is trapped
so it's a big decision I need to make
here because if my attack doesn't work
then I lose because I'll be down a
knight so what do you think attack you
can probably tell ya that I went for
this move now because the reason is if
you look at the position that I felt
like my attack is going to break through
because how many defenders he has around
the King not that many right and after I
play b5 I'm going to have my knight on
c5 very powerful two rooks on a B file I
will sacrifice my bishop so I will have
my queen also there and another strong
pawn on a5 so I will have so many pieces
attacking and his King is going to be
very weak so I decided to go for it to
sacrifice the night but I didn't
calculate to be honest all the way
through because that I am winning here
but leads calculate as much as I could
and just went for it because intuitively
I could tell that I should be winning
here so Bishop f8 as expected now my
knight is trapped now there is no way go
there is no way for me to go back now b5
finally we break through
he takes Bishop b5 sacrificing the
bishop he takes rook b5 now my opponent
played an excellent move okay let me
let's think about it for a few minutes
and I want to see if you can find his
move when I went for this I thought I'm
just winning there's just no defense
here I thought I will just go rook b6 I
mean I want to take on b7 also here a6 I
I really thought I'm just winning here
but he came up with a good move here to
defend and at least avoid getting
checkmated immediately so let's see if
we can find the best defensive move for
GM's private 96 is a possibility if it
was 96
can you find a forced mate forced make
now rook takes p7 excellent takes second
rook p7 takes Queen coming into play
check and make C after sacrificing a lot
of pieces checkmate on the board I was
hoping for something like this but he
made a move it's actually prevented well
if you go quickly 60 lose your queen so
and not enough compensation you lose the
Queen not enough compensation not aji
it's very good move it it wasn't very
simple for me to find a win after his
smooth little better version of that
move Knight to g8 the reason I cheat is
better because if you go to g6 after I
play rugby 6 I will have one more piece
coming in
because I can capture left six and then
come back to d5 and I'll have another
piece coming in okay so he played the
move Knight g8 defending on f6 and now
protecting on b7 and at the same time he
keeps the eye on the h6 square now if I
go for the same combination it's not
going to work because I don't have clean
8 6 is queen is guarding it that's fine
I cheat is a strong move because he
stopped my idea and now don't forget
that I already sacrifice one piece and
potentially the second piece is trapped
so I have to find the way to break
through here otherwise I will lose for
sure now what do you do here
you could try to push the a pawn but I
wasn't so sure what to do even after the
move b6 I know I can take but he
sacrifices his Queen and see I don't
have that many pieces left on the board
tonight on h5 is trapped any minute is
going to take this night with this
Bishop and I'm going to be left with the
Queen so even though I win his Queen
here but I actually lose my pieces you
know that I can attack with so that's
why I didn't go for a 6 but that's the
idea that I'm planning to do but you
need to do something first and then
think about that
absolutely rupees six attacking the
Queen controlling the be six squares so
he cannot play b6 himself now he has to
move the Queen which he did and now
don't rush
until you studio sacrifice the roots now
how a six take the be the visa with you
take with the bishop and if I take you
take the devil to move Thanks yeah you
could but I mean it's I mean I don't
have that many pieces left now but you
can take it and I know with it well I
don't think this is that clear
I mean I have a lot of plans but what
you have turned the rule there the G
Palermo if you beg unite in places it
yeah I mean I I'm probably I'm not worse
here probably but it's I'm not winning
here so it's just it's still a game here
maybe I'm a little bit better but I have
something much better than this so just
look at the position what do you think
you should do here if you see the
concrete ideas doesn't work what do you
do it normally yes what about night
night east six I'm going to fan back out
of there ninety-six enemy takes for the
bishop have I got it takes yeah again
this lines when I can get as Queen but
lose my rooks it's it's not very good
for me this lines well in particular
here I also lost my knight so it's not
so I I really need to bring more pieces
into the attack and also you need to
keep in mind he wants to take the knight
on c5 he's about to eliminate my
strongest attacking piece absolutely
bring one more piece into the game and
now after a six he cannot do anything he
can't sacrifice one be six a six threat
is very strong now so the only way for
him to do anything is to take this
Knight Bishop c5 I take and now he plays
f4 so he can go Bishop f5 check
and it looks like he's really defending
this and I'm down a piece my knight is
trapped on each wife it's not easy to
spot how I can try to win this position
now I have a strong move fish in for
then then he could take yet blacks the
bishop yes but when opponent is creating
a threat don't think about just defend
against history try to see if you can
create a stronger trap c6 it's a
possibility that's a possible move but
you have something stronger because
really if you think about it which line
you want to open so you can make this
King a one ok one is a good move to here
it's probably winning absolutely I went
a six because if he takes he played
Bishop a5 check but let's see if it
takes now I go rook a1 he takes my rook
do you see the mate yeah we take with
the visitor let's start with the Queen I
think this looks better so down lots of
material but again it's a mate ok so
that's why he didn't take because I go
to k1 so he goes Bishop f5 check by the
way Roo k1 move also works here I could
have start with this too but I went here
now he goes check King see one takes my
rook
I also that's my rock now
group table soap takes fun very good
it takes it takes again it's got lots of
pieces but if you play precisely you
will win this game now is winning - we
go Queen a5 check he goes here not yet
check this is more precise because we
want to tie up the night tonight cannot
move so he goes back and push even
technically he has more material here
because he's got two rooks Bishop and
night but actually these two pieces then
an early in the game and now the C pawn
is very strong so he played Group B 5
who's you check first if I do a pawn
push then he can bring his bishop back
to a5 and sacrifice for C a so that's
why I will check first he goes here push
now if let's say he plays this move
Bishop a4 can you find the checkmate
into your winning here but I needed to
find checkmate e2 c 8 equals 9
I guess we have an epic win here anyway
we put a knight here and if he goes to a
file
Queen 87 mate it goes to c5 Queen c7
made some trading to do an under
promotion to check his King so he played
here and now
can you find the best move after which
white wins immediately very good very
good not taking the night so you can
take the night but who in d8 is the
strongest move because now you're
threatening to go c8 and he cannot do
anything if he takes you take you get a
new queen and check it goes away we take
this and after this he can't do anything
okay white wins okay alright so I want
to go back now and go over this one more
time with you and actually I want you to
find all the moves okay for white so but
I'd like you to raise your hand if you
think you know the move raise your hand
and this way we'll do an over review of
the scheme so if you have some questions
you can ask okay okay all right so this
is the game from 2007 continental
championship against I'm white against
Grandmaster sprocket
okay I will play the moose for black you
will need to find all the moves here for
white okay okay okay okay so so we still
go with d4 that's easy Dutch defense
right okay next go ahead my to c3 Knight
to c3 Knight f6 now what's the move
Bishop Bishop g5 d5 bishop takes now
Jason you need to get your pieces
developed right remember remember we
don't put a knight on f3 here remember
in this position you don't put a knight
on f3 because you put a knight on f3
Knight doesn't have many prospects
because this pawn is going to be
controlling your knife so don't put a
knight on f3 okay get reversed III first
yes this should be seasoned and now
remember the move Queen Queen f3 develop
the Queen first to put some pressure on
the pants on d5 and f5 now goes here and
now yes it should be 5 very good
developing the bishop and also peeling
the knife yes followed by 92 excellent
remember very important to remember the
night belongs only to if you play this
position against - defense put your
night on e - ok because you have more
possibilities especially in particular
you want to go to the f4 square now you
castles it's gonna get a little harder
now yeah 9a 4
are you sure a 3-step okay if you go 90
for Queen before check okay so you have
to play a three first to control the
before square it's a very useful move a
3 in this position to control the square
and then you can go for 94 ok 9 goes
King B 8
just 9a for absolutely C night doesn't
have very good potential on c3 so you
want to improve the night and put it on
c5 and that's what I'm trying to do here
9a 497 continue yes I just when we go
back there
what is that King move it is looks to me
like it's a lost cat woman
oh she's very she sees running the same
on yeah but he sees the attack potential
attack coming and night is coming to
Safari so he wants to have that square
for the Bishop to retreat in general in
this type of positions you want to put
the king if you castle long usually you
want to you know make it time and go
over to you know make sure you're a pawn
is protect and here in particular he
wants to have the bishop on C so you can
defend against the attack because
imagine if when I was attacking him he
didn't have the bishop - you remember
the position right imagine if he had a
bishop on f7 not on c8 you've been over
very quickly I would have just
sacrificed on a6 but his bishop on C it
was preventing me from the sacrifice
when I had a knight on c5 Bishop on d3
Queen only - I could have just
sacrificed and then queen eight six so
you will see now again so this is no
this mu is okay now 97 now continue
bishop ca
g3 a prophylactic idea you don't always
want to wait until he makes a threat for
you to stop it you want to make these
prophylactic moves in advance to make
sure he doesn't get any contra play on
this side of the world on it because
black wants to get a counter play on the
Kings side and you're going to be
playing on a queen side here so it was
h5 threatening to play h4 yes exactly
stopping him and now but black is
extremely solid usually it's very
difficult to break those kind of
positions because I mean he doesn't
really have any weaknesses I need to
really work hard here to create some
weaknesses first before gaining space
you remember the plan now c3 first
because I want to play a four a five I
can play a four now because after he
plays b6 I'm going to have a problem
with my pawn my pawn will be hanging
some lines so that's why I want to play
c3 first and by the way if you please
now b6 it's risky for him because I can
also go night a6f but in a previous line
I couldn't because he would have
captured and take my pan on before so
that's why I need to protect the before
square before pawn before I play a four
so you guys King a eight now continue
with the plan
not yet we do night the four legs of 84
first remember a six Bishop d3 now I
walk in D to kick a7 threatening to play
b6 to move my knight from c5 so what do
I do here
yes remember c5 Knight is my best minor
piece here and I want to make sure this
night stays there and now he sees the B
fact red coming so you play c6 looks
like position is very close and it's
going to be difficult to do anything
cash and here what you need to find the
plan here you remember my move not
afford first activating the knight now
putting some more pressure now he can't
even move his Knight
so in this position he can really move
that many pieces his knife he cannot
move the knight he can I move the Queen
96 fork so he goes here rook h8
PC - yeah even though you could probably
keep your king there but you don't want
to be on that same diagonal with the
bishop so because maybe we'll have some
tactics later on so that's why it's
safer for you to have the King on see -
here it goes here it is that but first
improve the Queen remember Queen needs
to be improved for us to be five fork so
Queen to e2 it probably doesn't matter
which movie do first but I did this
okay b1 rugby - and here here a choice
to wait until I develop my rooks and
play b5 and really break through or try
to create complications and in this kind
of positions you always go for some
complications at least if you're going
to lose some material because you want
to have some chances so you made the
right decision g5 now it goes here group
a joke H / yes we want to go for the
mate
basically we just we're going to go all
the way now with the attack not taking
here which is good but we're just up
upon it's possible that you know we
might not win if it plays very well and
yes chances but with the attack we can
break through now Bishop f8 e b5 takes
rook takes first so now remember the
best defense for him here what was the
best defense for him Knight G a very
difficult move to find how many of you
think if you had this position you would
play Knight g8 anybody think you can
play you play Nige 8i yeah I mean I was
looking at some other lines - I didn't
like to be honest I didn't expect it
that much I mean I knew my attack is
very strong but 98 was excellent on his
part
yes how is my GI well denied g6 i we
talked about that already
Knight on g6 I when I go to p6 your f6
pawn will be handing and my knight will
capture the pawn and I will have an
extra piece attacking but when you go to
g8 you protect on the f6 right back
where you started from you like
development nightly basis I understand
but at this point is black block is
about to get made it at this point he
can't think about development he just
needs to think about not getting made it
so that's fine
you could go on a g6 but after this I
think the game and even quickly because
I'll have extra piece coming in similar
play but I will in some lines I will
also have Knight xf6
making the pawn attacking the rook and
that piece also will join the attack so
it goes 98 now how do you break through
here it's not that clear it's not that
easy to see from p6 Queen c7 now Queen
b5 bring one more piece into the game he
takes the night away
f-4c when a product makes a move like
this we tend to immediately think about
okay is threating Bishop by five we have
to do something to stop that don't think
like I try to see if he has a thread you
try to create a stronger thread a six we
go for the brake too now if he takes you
remember right the move okay one takes
sacrifice
so if they check I went to king c1
Bishop takes and now it's very important
at the final stages when you're about to
win you may ensure you play precise
because a lot of times if you don't play
precise at the end you're going to give
your opponent a chance to get back into
the game in a winning position play
precise the rook takes pawn check
he takes pawn takes threatening to queen
so he has to take queen if I check see
if you play c6 here he can play rook c7
minute Wow
so we go check first now these two
pieces cannot move right and then c6
he's tied up and I also have a lot of
pawns so Rock b5 another precise check
needed here see if you push this pawn
then you probably still winning but then
you will go here and when you Queen he
can sacrifice so that's why you first go
check to control that f5 score so he
cannot bring the bishop back and after
going here go here and if you place your
bishop efore checkmate in to remember c8
9 you always have to think about that
because if you go c8 Queen guess what's
going to happen
perpetual check imagine it will be very
sad you know with two queens and all
this winning chances to get into a
perpetual and I can't escape now
especially in the Bliss game is possible
to get a Nuke win and then suddenly see
can't escape check but of course we're
not going to do that we're going to
remember about under promotion and then
you go see eight nine and then if it
goes to the a six or eight seven Queen
eight seven mate if it goes to c5 Queen
c7 mate so you can read escape so he
goes 97 and now the final move after I
mean you can take the knight at all so
we but the strongest move is Queen d8
very good and now if it takes the Queen
you take back check and pick up the
night and also your turn to go c8 check
and now he cannot really do anything
well remove the rule itself you know you
tear an idea now I will get my second
queen with the check discover check
second Queen check and is this this
might be a maid no it's not a mate yet
but so just remain here so okay very
good
do you have any questions about this
game you want ask yes
he didn't strike it seemed like he put
really solidly for a long time to
realize just like you strive for kind of
like too late maybe it's a good question
it looks like but the thing is when when
like I mean here here I mean he could
try something like that but I don't
think he really realized how strong my
attack is gonna be he thought maybe he
can just it's locked and I don't think
he's so that I can build up all this
it's very hard to see all this in the
game but I mean in this position he
can't really create that's why I put the
pawn on g3 and fh4 because I'm really
stopping his counter play if you play
each five here I will capture a g5 I
will just capture and I win the h5 pawn
with a rock that's why I'm keeping my
rook here because I'm anticipating
something like that g5 and if you play a
four I don't think you really will get
that much contra play here I will just I
can capture with the knight or even
capture with the pond and it's very
solid for white so yeah he he didn't
think that probably my attack is gonna
be that strong and that's why he just
thought he can just you know he's solid
he can hold the position and but I have
this very strong plan with doubling up
my rooks and going for b5 okay so he
really doesn't have a plan like a
concrete plant that he could have done
he could have sacrificed a pawn but then
I don't think really he has enough
compensation okay any other questions
yes
the first time but why did he move it
again today right there uh it's a good
question and I mean you think you should
have just played this plan immediately
maybe you're right maybe he could have
just played a6 Bishop d3 and then go
King a 7 yeah and then play b6 one more
he's picked up a temple I don't know how
significant is the temple here but could
be but but I think here is I just still
go here a4 and when you play v6 I could
just go to b3 and then try to play a 5
again
I mean why he's still better but this
probably would have been better for him
to do but then again I go a5 and get my
c5 squash ok all right ok any other
questions about this game ok
you understand the ideas how I set up
the pieces and how to break through in
the closed position C position was very
close and I think I mean look at this
position we don't even exchange the pawn
we've only exchanged one piece so all
the pieces are on the board but there
are not that many moves here for me or
for him also so I really have to this
was the important moment in the game
here and again as you notice all my
pants here on the dark squares you don't
see that many games and positions like
this where you have eight pants on the
same color but really my last words are
not weak my bishop is doing a good job
controlling a lot of the squares and the
most important thing is black is
squeezed here
he doesn't have freedom of moving his
pieces here and the main goal for black
in this position is to get an eye to e4
but it's a very long shot here to get
the night only fortune yes I got a
question anything about that but like
it's a lot it's not a change they got
names at the variation they got names
yes how many moves do you think you go
when you just don't act out the one and
go with your all Internet
thank you well it's a a well point was
no longer to be the English open it
really depends on a line it really
depends on online certain lines you have
to go really deep because it's very
concrete and if you go wrong you could
lose immediately certain lines you could
know the first ten moves and kind of get
the pieces out and just play chess so
the degree depends on what kind of line
you're playing if you're playing
Sicilian dragon you have to know 25 or
20 moves theory because you go one more
wrong you're going to get made it it
really depends but if you pay a French
defense you will need to know
twenty-five moves theory you can know
I'm ten fifteen moves it really depends
on all the link you choose so sharper
openings you have to know more theory
you play King's Indian you play
twenty-five moves if you look at a lot
of the top games in 2010 Kings India now
they they play 1st 2025 moves maybe in
two minutes let's create critical
positions that have to move 25 for
example so it really depends on a
position ok ok great I think we're going
to take a break now and then we're going
to continue